Hi, everyone. My name is Martin Cousins.
I'm going to be your host for this training session
into Introduction to AI in Unreal Engine
for Programmers for Unreal 5.5.
So what are we going to cover today?
We've got looking into the AI Controller, Behavior Tree,
Blackboard, Navigation Mesh, EQS,
or the Environmental Query System, AI Perception,
and then a little bit about some of the useful plugins
that can be useful tools in your belt
if you're working with AI stuff.
So that's smart objects, state trees,
mass entity, and lastly the zone graph.
So first off the AI Controller.
Now this is the third session in a series of five.
So some of these, this initial concept
is going to be a little bit of repetition
from previous sessions that you may have seen,
but just as a kind of like building up the basis again.
So when we're talking about the AI Controller,
this is a controller that is specifically designed
to possess and control AI objects.
It's a non-physical actor that can possess a pawn
like any controller can.
It's got a couple of functions made available to it
through onPossess and onUnPossess,
meaning the AI Controller can be notified.
And what the AI Controller,
and generally controllers in broad
are kind of meant to represent
is the kind of a will of the thing
that they are controlling.
So in this context, being the AI Controller,
it's kind of represents the will of an AI entity,
an AI actor.
That can be any agent.
Typically it's going to be
some kind of humanoid-esque character, probably,
but really this could be there
to kind of represent any controllable pawn
and represent its kind of logic and thinking.
Whereas the pawn is meant to be there
to represent the actual physical actions
being performed in the world.
As with other controllers,
AI Controllers have a one-to-one relationship
with the pawn.
If you have something like a hack and slash
where you want kind of mob behavior
and you want 20 enemies being controlled by one manager,
that's not really the kind of fundamental basis
for an AI Controller.
It is intended to have a one controller controls one pawn,
one pawn is controlled by a single controller.
So if you need something else,
you might need to look into
a more bespoke implementation.
The standard intent for an AI Controller
is a one-to-one relationship.
So a couple of notes about the AI Controller.
It only exists on the server.
We've spoken about this before
in our second session on Gameplay Framework,
but essentially the server
is really what houses all the controllers.
For player controllers, each individual client player
will see their own player controller.
But really it is just a general pervading logic.
The server is the authoritative state
and therefore it should be the server
making all the decisions about what the AIs are doing.
And therefore the AI controllers,
which are the brain should exist on the server.
And really all the AI pawns
are there to do on each individual client
is kind of mimics the behavior
that the server is deciding.
You wouldn't want a clash
between different bits of AI logic.
You wouldn't want an AI on the client side
to be thinking one thing
and the AI on the server side
to be thinking another thing.
So all of that logic is centralized on the server
and it's simply the clients kind of parrot the actions
of what the brain decides to do.
So the AI Controller houses kind of four main components.
The behavior tree component,
which inherits from the brain component.
So it's pretty explicit there.
It's kind of the thing that actually does the thinking.
The blackboard component.
So if you think of,
we'll talk more about blackboards in a bit,
but this is essentially the,
close thing is the memory,
the way they're kind of,
the brain kind of hold onto data between frames
across time for use later.
Perception component, pretty self-explanatory.
This is essentially how the AI
can sense things about the world.
We'll go into more detail about that later.
And then lastly, the path following component,
which is how AI agents follow paths
use the navigation system that Unreal provides.
This didn't used to be the case,
but in more recent versions of Unreal,
I don't have the exact point
at which this became a thing to hand,
but in more recent versions of Unreal,
AIs can now kind of initiate the AI logic
as soon as they get possessed.
They didn't used to be able to do this,
but if I just quickly jump to the engine,
that is through,
if we go into an AI controller,
there has a,
there's a bull called start AI logic on possess.
So if that's ticked,
then as soon as that AI controller gets initializes,
as soon as it possesses an entity,
it will start its AI logic
if it has a behavior tree component
already on the controller.
We'll get into more of this later.
Importantly, AI controllers implement
what's called a generic team interface.
This is something that you,
I don't believe you can perceive in blueprint
because it is more of a C plus plus concept.
So if we just quickly jump to the C plus plus,
we can actually see this.
If I just go to ai-controller.h,
generic team, yeah.
And you can see that it implements this interface.
This interface is really a way for controllers
and other entities in the world.
It's Unreal's built-in way for entities
to perceive themselves and each other
as part of a particular team,
as they kind of name would imply.
So this is useful for some of the perception components
we'll get to in a little bit.
It helps basically entities give an idea of like,
should I treat this thing as an enemy?
Should I treat this thing as a friend
or am I neutral to it?
The standard implementation is as soon as two agents
are on different teams, they're automatically enemies.
We'll get into that more in a bit,
but just know that Unreal has a default implementation
of the idea of teams.
Then by default, that's on the AI controller
and it kind of implements it.
I think it just goes to,
I think the default implementation is
it's just the default team, which is like,
I think the teams are represented by a byte
and so they're just team 255, like the maximum.
And you would have to kind of manually
implement that yourselves.
But just again, worth mentioning that the agent,
the interface can be implemented on objects,
but it isn't a blueprint interface.
So none of this functionality is exposed to blueprint
and would have to be kind of driven on C++,
but that is there.
And then, yeah, last of all,
it's kind of just worth mentioning
that we've got a kind of entry function
for selecting possible targets based on our perception.
We have this function,
actors perception updated function,
which sends through an array of any actors
that have been recently perceived.
And then that way the AI can kind of make decisions
about possible targets for its various logic.
So that's the behavior tree.
Next, we have the good kind of going into,
in the broad at least, going into kind of more detail.
As we already mentioned, we have the behavior tree itself.
The behavior tree component
is really what hosts the behavior tree.
So the behavior tree component
is the kind of brain of the AI agent.
It inherits from brain components, as I already mentioned,
and it's actually held on the AI controller.
AI controllers won't have a brain component automatically.
You can either add one
or you can generate one at runtime by calling it on C++.
We'll go into that in a little bit.
You can call a function at runtime
to kind of create a behavior tree component
if one doesn't already exist.
We'll go into more detail about that in a minute.
But a couple of things about the behavior tree component.
It does make an assumption
that the owner is an AI controller.
So we talked about this again,
I think in the second session,
but essentially these two things are tightly linked.
Behavior tree component without an AI controller
doesn't really make sense.
So it does kind of, the behavior tree component
is aware of the AI controller
that should be holding onto it.
It even has functions like getAIOwner,
which really, really strongly implied that, you know,
this component is meant to be held by an AI.
The, yeah, it's a blueprint spawnable component,
so you can add it onto your controllers
if you kind of want that preset up.
As I already mentioned,
that idea of running logic on possess doesn't work
if you haven't pre-added a behavior tree component yourself,
but there are other ways of doing it.
You can run a behavior tree at runtime
and that will automatically add a behavior tree component
if one doesn't already exist to the AI controller.
Yep.
So, as we already said, it exposes,
the behavior tree component itself
exposes what behavior tree you want to use.
One will be created at runtime
if we choose to run a behavior tree,
if that's not present.
It's the behavior tree component
that's in charge of running that behavior tree
and it doesn't come automatically attached.
So just to kind of actually quickly demonstrate this,
if I were to just make some new AI controller,
make a blueprint that inherits from AI controller,
we could see that no behavior tree exists.
We can very quickly add one ourselves.
Sorry, English spelling a behavior there, my bad.
So yeah, we can just add a behavior tree ourselves
and like I said, this run,
or is it start?
Yeah, start AI won't work
unless there is a behavior tree added,
but the other way we can do that is through this function,
which is run behavior tree,
and you essentially provide a behavior tree to run
and it will automatically create
an appropriate behavior tree component.
So those are the kind of two ways of doing it.
So the behavior tree itself,
we talked a little bit about the component.
The behavior tree is obviously essentially is,
as we said, the brain.
It allows us, it's a way
of structuring decision-making essentially.
It can be paired with blackboards to,
which introduced the concept of memory to make decisions,
gather up information about the world it's in
and make decisions based off that information.
It's essentially built in a hierarchical manner.
It's a set of nodes that control
the flow of decision-making.
So it might, for people who aren't used
to seeing things like behavior trees,
it might look a little bit like a flow diagram.
And when you're creating a behavior tree,
it has its own editor graph.
So when you might already be used to blueprinting,
if you go into a behavior tree,
it's gonna look a little bit different
because as with several systems in Unreal,
it has its own kind of bespoke editor.
The other thing that's worth mentioning
is a lot of behavior tree logic is event-driven.
It's not really on tick, even though it might look like it.
A lot of what the behavior tree is doing
is sitting and waiting for updates
from whatever is the kind of most relevant node.
So this is just an example
of a behavior tree that we've got here.
This is one, if you download the example project,
this is the behavior tree
that we've already got in our fundamentals folder.
If we go to fundamentals behavior tree,
it's just this BT example.
And essentially this is just a very, very simple setup.
In a kind of fully shift game,
it's much more likely that we would have
a far more substantial setup.
We're gonna go into what each of these nodes is
and how they work very briefly in a little bit, sorry.
But kind of very briefly just to talk about it,
what this is ultimately doing
is behavior trees are importantly structured
top to bottom, left to right.
And you can actually see that denoted
by these little numbers on each of these nodes.
You can see no two of them share a number.
This is the order of priority of these nodes.
So as we can see,
we'll go into what each of these nodes actually is
and what they do, but we have our first node here.
So this is zero,
and then this would be the second node considered.
And then we would always get to this sequence.
Again, we'll talk more about what these do, three, four, five.
And then only after all of these are considered,
then we would go over here.
So the left to rightness of these nodes is very important.
An interesting caveat or an interesting just eccentricity
of the behavior tree system to be aware of
is that the way in which the left to rightness
of these nodes is assessed
might not always be completely obvious.
So one might assume that because this node
is now kind of the arrow is pointing more to the left,
this node would be higher priority.
That's actually not the case.
You can see this has still been assigned four
and this has been assigned three.
It's actually the left most side of the node
is used to assess whether or not one node
is higher priority.
It's a strange little quirk of the system,
but just important to be aware of
because if you have particularly long names,
it can actually end up in a situation
where your nodes act in perhaps slightly surprising ways.
So purely because this runEQS query is so wide
because the name is so long,
it's actually ended up being a higher priority.
But as soon as that becomes even slightly more to the right,
you see this now shifts down in priority.
So that's just the left to rightness is preserved here,
but it's just what exactly that means
in the context of particularly long names.
If I just gave this some absurdly long name,
you can overwrite the names of the nodes.
If I just change this to move to some long name
and I just add a load of ease.
Well, that's shifted it all to the right.
But either way, you might want to centralize that, right?
That might seem like it makes sense,
but now suddenly, if I were to save this.
Okay, well, for some reason,
maybe it doesn't actually read the override name
that you choose, but I've definitely had this before
when I've had long function names
that it has...
Oh no, yeah, that is done exactly as we expected.
Sorry, no, I misread the...
But as you can see, we've got a very long name now
and this is now node three and this is node four
because the left side has been pushed so far to the side.
So just a little quirk that's worth bearing in mind.
But yeah, generally what this is doing
is we can assume that the kind of leftmost behavior
is the highest priority behavior
and this is the kind of fallback behavior.
We've got a behavior tree that's essentially
choosing to do some behavior.
If we have a target,
then we try and find a point around the target.
We move to them and then we attack them.
And if we don't, so this is the higher priority.
If we have a target,
we'll go into how we're achieving that in a little bit.
And then the fallback behavior
is we just find some location around us,
we wait for five seconds
and then we move to that location and just repeat that.
So that's what this behavior tree is doing.
It's relatively simple.
Again, in a kind of full release game,
you would expect to see quite a lot
more sizable behavior trees,
but this is just introducing some simple concepts,
the general structure that behavior tree might have
and just to kind of demonstrate
how each of these nodes works.
So we've already kind of taken a little look
at some of these nodes,
but the actual behavior tree is made up
of five key groups of nodes.
We have the root node, composite nodes
with which there are three different types,
and then task nodes, decorators, and surfaces.
And we'll go into each of those in more detail now.
So the root node, this is just our start point.
It can't be deleted.
The root node can only have one connection.
And if the connection from the root node
to any other nodes is disconnected,
then essentially the entire behavior tree is disabled.
We'll talk more about what decorators
and surfaces are in a second,
but the root node can't have decorators
or surfaces attached to it.
And it's kind of got no inherent functionality.
It's really just an entry point.
And if you are to select the root node,
really all you're doing
is talking about the behavior tree as a whole.
So the kind of default behavior,
whereas with most of the nodes,
you can kind of set properties about them.
You can specify bits of information about that node itself.
The root node, all you do is no different
to kind of clicking off in the behavior tree in general.
All you do is assign the blackboard,
but that is kind of,
that's nothing to do with the root.
That's the behavior tree itself.
It's just to say that the root node
kind of has no extra information that you can set.
So then we have composite nodes.
Composite nodes essentially define our,
kind of a branch in our behavior tree's logic.
And each different kind of composite node
determines rules for how that branch is executed.
Only composite nodes can be attached to the root node.
So tasks, decorators, surfaces
can't be utilized directly off the root node.
The first node that your root node enters into
needs to be a composite node.
And composite node, unlike the root node,
do support both decorators and surfaces.
As you said, there are three types of competent nodes.
We have selectors, sequences, and simple parallels,
and we'll kind of go into those in more detail now.
So first off, we have selectors.
Selectors essentially,
kind of two, we've talked about kind of priority,
but the other important concept to understand
in behavior trees is there is this concept
of success and failure.
Nodes could really have three states.
They have, they can succeed, they can fail,
or they can be kind of pending.
They can be, you know, not finished yet.
But ultimately, once a node concludes,
it will either succeed or fail.
So the purposes of selectors and sequences
is respond in different ways
to this idea of success and failure.
The purpose of selector, as kind of implied by the name,
is there to select a particular behavior.
So a selector can have multiple children,
and what the selector is there to do
is find the first successful child.
So it goes from left to right,
as with all behavior trees by default.
It will go from left to right
through each of the children
and find the first child that succeeds
and then return itself.
So a selector, you enter the selector,
the selector goes from left, assesses the first child.
If that child succeeds,
the selector itself will instantly succeed
and exit out.
And then, you know, if the flow returns to the selector,
it will then start from the beginning again.
If the first child fails,
then it will move on to the next child
and ask that child if it succeeds or fail.
And the selector will keep going left to the right
as long as the children keep failing
until it gets to the last child.
And if the last child fails,
then the entire selector fails.
So as well as the children having concepts
of failing and succeeding,
the selector itself has a concept of failing and succeeding.
The selector fails if all of its children fail.
As soon as the selector finds one child that succeeds,
the selector itself succeeds and exits out.
The sequence is kind of the opposite, the inversion.
So where the selector is trying to find a single node
that succeeds,
the sequence is trying to,
essentially is intending to execute all of its children
and will stop as soon as it hits one that fails.
So whereas the selector expects one succeeding child,
the sequencer kind of hopes,
as much as, you know, code desires anything,
for all of its children to succeed,
as I'm sure we all do in life.
So the same as selector,
the same as all behavior trees run left to right,
a sequence will execute its leftmost child first.
If that child fails,
the sequence will instantly itself fail and exit out.
If that child succeeds,
it moves to the right onto its next child
and will proceed and will keep executing the next child
when the previous child succeeds.
If the previous child succeeds,
as soon as one of them fails,
it will exit out of the behavior and continue onwards.
And then lastly, we have simple parallel.
This is less for controlling flow and more just
it's kind of useful bit of functionality.
Essentially, we have a kind of main task
that the parallel executes.
It's important to mention that what the parallel,
the kind of parallel node does,
is it executes a tree whilst performing a task.
So the task itself must be a task node,
which again, we'll talk about next.
And then what it expects from the kind of second branch
is likely going to be a composite node.
You could maybe plug a task into that as well.
I've never tried that myself,
but the typical plan would be to have a, you know,
an entire kind of other branch of your tree.
And that branch is executed
whilst the primary task is being executed.
An example of this might be you have some kind of
look at player logic that you want to execute
whilst attacking the player or something like that.
So you can perform actions in the background
whilst you're doing a certain thing.
The other thing that you have
is this finish mode variable.
You can, if I were to just quickly add in a parallel node,
I don't think I've got one here,
but if I add in a parallel,
you can see you've got a couple of different finish modes.
You have immediate and delayed.
Immediate essentially means as soon as the task finishes,
the tree that is underneath it gets aborted.
So it stops executing regardless of what it's doing.
Otherwise we have delayed where when the task,
whatever task is plugged in here,
finishes, concludes, succeeds, or fails,
the tree will get to its own natural finish state
before then exiting out.
So that's all of our composite nodes.
Next, we have task nodes.
Task nodes are essentially the nodes that do things.
It's again, implied by the name.
And they essentially,
this is like a little bit like our function call.
They're the things that do things.
The majority of a behavior tree
is likely to be made up of task nodes.
And task nodes themselves support decorators and services
and are obviously intended to be placed
on the behavior tree graph.
There's a couple of preexisting task nodes,
but you can also make your own in Blueprint,
which we'll talk about a little bit more in a bit.
But just some examples of kind of preexisting ones
is if you just look under,
if you right click inside a behavior tree
and you've got tasks,
these are the ones we've made ourselves,
but you can see the kind of things
that you might already have available to you
in the engine.
Move to being a very, very common one
that's obviously using the nav system,
playing sounds, playing animations,
running an EQS query.
You can see the kinds of things
that you might use a task for.
Next, we have decorators.
As has kind of already been mentioned,
decorators can be added to either composites or task nodes.
And decorators essentially give us a way
to inject branching kind of conditions onto our logic.
So yeah, other behavior trees,
obviously behavior trees aren't a unique to Unreal.
They have their own kind of like bespoke implementation,
but obviously behavior trees are a concept
that exists outside of Unreal as a whole.
So the terminology here might be slightly different,
but I believe these would be called conditionals
in other behavior tree systems.
So essentially we can add decorators to other nodes,
be that composite nodes or task nodes,
and they give us a way to kind of affect
the context in which that node will actually execute.
And in certain contexts,
depending on the kind of decorator that you've got applied,
you can actually even use that decorator
to abort out of other parts of the tree.
We said it before about this idea
of behavior trees being event-based.
Some of that event-based behavior
really comes out in this idea
that we kind of listen to changes within our,
or we can listen to changes within our decorators
for when that decorator state changes,
we can instantly alter our behavior.
So particularly in the context of a decorator,
this is an example of one that we've used in this tree
where we've got a decorator
that is listening to a blackboard key.
We'll talk more about blackboard keys in a little bit,
but essentially just imagine this is a variable
and this variable can change.
And this is an if saying
that we don't want to perform all of this logic
if this variable doesn't have a valid value in it.
But as well as that,
we have the ability to kind of abort parts of the tree.
So as you can see here,
this isn't true for all blackboards, for all decorators,
but for some of them,
particularly blackboard-based decorators,
we have this option for kind of aborting.
And you can kind of see
we've got these different options here.
We can not abort at all.
We can abort just the tree itself.
We can abort any part of the behavior tree
that is lower priority than this node.
And we can do both.
We can abort this part of the tree itself
and everything that is lower priority.
And the two situations which we can abort
is when the result has changed.
So this depends on what query
are we asking about this variable
and has the output of that query changed?
Is it true or false?
And the other situation in which we can react to that
is when the value itself,
so the data being plugged in,
our actual, the value inside our variable has changed
regardless of whether or not
we're going to react to it in a different way,
regardless of whether our output is true or false,
just because the input data has changed,
we want to possibly abort in that situation.
So it gives us this kind of very powerful logic
to react to things more instantaneously
only in certain situations,
only in certain priority levels.
So we'll just change that back to,
I think this was set to kind of lower priority.
So that's decorators.
And then lastly, we have service nodes.
Service nodes are essentially give us a way to implement
almost in the background behavior.
They essentially execute,
they are a kind of node that you attach,
as we already said, to either composites or tasks,
and they will execute on a defined frequency
as long as the node that they are attached to
or the part of the branch that they are attached to
is being executed.
So we've got an example in the behavior tree here.
We've got a, this is a very, very common one.
I think the only default engine service
is to run an EQS.
This EQS actually isn't doing anything,
but it's just kind of there to demonstrate its use.
But essentially as long as we are within
one of these nodes within this part of the tree,
this EQS will be, this service will be running.
And what it will be doing is on an interval of 0.5 seconds
with a variance of 0.1.
So between every 0.4 to 0.6 seconds,
we will run an EQS query.
We will talk more about what an EQS query actually is
a little bit later, but you know,
this same thing could apply to any logic,
swap EQS query out for whatever logic you want to do.
It could be try and find a possible reload point.
So try and find the most powerful weapon in the map
on a periodic, like every 10 seconds,
just check if the most powerful weapon in the map
has spawned in and then maybe we would want to react
to that logic in some way.
So again, they are essentially time-based logic
that will execute whilst their part of the tree
is being executed.
Obviously, if you were to add a service to a task,
then that service would only execute
whilst that task is being executed.
So it's a little bit like running parallel behavior.
In some ways, the parallel node and service nodes
kind of perform a somewhat similar function.
Yeah, as we already said,
EQS is one of the kind of preexisting ones
that exist in Unreal.
And yeah, it's important to mention
that services don't have to tick.
They can also, they can just be used
for kind of like entry and exit logic
for when their tree,
part of the tree has been entered and exited.
And knowledge of relevancy from networking
can also be kind of leveraged within them.
As with tasks decorators,
and really all of the fundamental parts
of the behavior tree system,
all of this stuff can be created in Blueprint and C++.
So when we're talking about behavior trees in general,
one of the things that's worth mentioning
is the fact that all of these nodes,
when we see a behavior tree,
it might be an expectation
that when we have multiple AIs running this behavior tree,
each AI would end up with a copy of that behavior tree.
And to a degree, they do.
But when you have multiple AIs
using the same behavior tree,
actually the default behavior
is that each of these nodes
is shared between each of the AIs.
So if you have 20 AIs
running this BT example behavior tree,
this selector, this sequence,
this run EQS query would by default all be shared.
So there is actually only one EQS query.
There's only one sequence.
There is only one selector that all of these AIs share.
That is the default implementation for nodes.
Obviously this comes with certain benefits.
It's improved CPU usage, it's improved memory usage.
We just don't need to use or do as much stuff.
But obviously when we want kind of like instanced
or agent-specific data,
that becomes a little bit of a challenge, right?
The fact that all of this information is always shared
between everyone using that behavior tree
has performance advantages,
but it comes at the cost of we have all of the
information that is used across these things is shared.
And so that is kind of undesirable for obvious reasons.
So in comes the various ways
that we can kind of introduce this concept,
introduce ways to provide
that kind of more instance-based logic.
So the first example is we have instancing nodes.
This is essentially for particular nodes
in our behavior tree.
We can introduce the idea that this node,
for every copy of this node, it will be an instance.
So it won't be shared by each person
using this behavior tree.
For every agent using this behavior tree,
you would have a copy of this node.
That's what an instance node does.
This is defined in C++.
I don't believe you can define this in Blueprint,
and you would do it typically in the constructor.
So this is just an example in the,
we'll talk about this specifically in a second,
but from the C++ for the Blueprint base,
which is when you're going to make your own
behavior tree tasks,
you would inherit from Blueprint base,
and you can see this be create node instances set to true.
So there are a couple of other nodes that use this
by default in the engine.
Play animation, run behavior tree dynamic
would also use this.
But essentially whenever you're creating
a behavior tree node that you want to be instanced,
so you don't want to be shared
by all instances of this behavior tree,
you would use, in the constructor,
you would set this be create node instance to true.
And then obviously every agent that uses that node,
even if you use that node multiple times within your tree,
there would be a unique copy
for each of those instances in that tree
for each node, for each agent using that tree.
Obviously this comes with performance
and memory usage costs.
You are essentially duplicating data.
More things need to be performed against.
There are more nodes that the CPU has to consider.
So these obviously has certain performance costs.
So you should really only be using these
when you don't feel there is a way
to kind of achieve this another way.
The other way that you can do this
is through node memory.
So again, this is more of a C plus plus concept.
The node memory isn't really available
to the blueprint end of things,
but it essentially allows us to create
a kind of custom struct or class
that represents an individual node's memory.
And then that memory will automatically be passed around
by functions within the C plus plus,
within native implementation of that node.
And you can access and utilize that memory.
There's a function that essentially defines
how big this block of memory is.
So we'll actually just quickly look at the C plus plus
for this, it's probably the best example.
So if we look at the BT task move two,
and if I were to, wrong node there,
if we were to just jump in here,
there's a couple of nodes that we kind of need
to be aware of.
So first off we have the get instance memory size.
So this is essentially saying,
how big does the block of memory need to be
for whatever memory this node is gonna need?
So obviously this would be done on a case by case basis,
but the typical thing is you would implement
some struct or class that represents the memory
that this node needs.
And then you would fill it with all that data.
And then really, as long as you're not doing anything
kind of like crazy or dynamic,
you can just use size of to return
just whatever the size of that struct or class is.
And then that's all you kind of need to fill in.
Then with all of the functions that this,
well, certainly a lot of the functions
that this node can utilize,
that memory is exposed to that function
through this UN8 pointer.
Obviously this is just a pointer
to the kind of like start point of that memory.
And so you would just need to cast that.
So typically you'll see this in,
this is an example,
the move to node is an existing unreal node
that utilizes this functionality.
But you can see here that we are kind of casting
that memory to our actual struct
and then utilizing the memory from that structure.
This is how you would utilize it.
And the other two functions just to be aware of
is this initialize memory and cleanup memory
where you essentially create your instance
of this struct and you clean up
that instance of that struct.
So those are the kind of things to be aware of
when you're using this.
And as you've already seen,
there are examples in the engine
that already utilize this, you can use for reference.
And the other thing to mention is that this,
whatever this memory is,
it's not part of the U object data system.
So you wouldn't be making a,
if you were to make a struct or a class,
this wouldn't be inheriting from U object.
This is stuff that it needs to be manually
created, managed, and cleaned up.
But as we already saw, we have these initialize memory
and cleanup memory functions specifically for that.
So yeah, these are some examples
of where we might be using those.
I think I've kind of already covered,
we've got our initialization, we've got our cleanup.
This is how we might use it within a task.
So we've got this pointer to our memory here, we cast it.
And then similarly, we've also got here an example
of how even outside of one of those functions
that passes in the kind of memory pointer,
as long as we have access to the task node itself,
you can, well, as long as we have access
to the behavior tree component,
and yeah, we can use this get node memory
and then find the instance containing this node
and then get the memory in that way.
So there are ways outside of the node itself
to actually access this stuff if that's required.
And then the last example,
which is more blueprint facing
and is kind of probably going to be the most common way
to manage this memory is through blackboard storage.
We already kind of mentioned the idea
of the blackboard being the way,
the kind of agent's memory.
And so yeah, blackboard storage
is obviously a way to do that.
Essentially, blackboard storage can be accessed
within any individual node.
You just need to pass in a particular,
you need to expose a particular property.
The variable that you'd be exposing
is called a blackboard key selector.
And what that lets us do is it kind of lets us get
and set data from and to a given blackboard.
The kind of thing to bear in mind
that whenever you are working with this
is it will only support a kind of like subset of types
that are suitable for blackboards,
but that does cover the vast majority of situations.
Yeah, so the blackboard data itself
is really the memory of our AI.
We've covered the way that individual nodes
can kind of have this memory so we can instance them.
The node itself can have memory
on a kind of per node basis.
But if we, generally the blackboard
is where we kind of would handle the agent's
more global memory to be possibly shared
between different nodes.
So yeah, the blackboard data is a kind of agent's memory.
And it is, the blackboard itself
is specifically engineered to work alongside
the behavior tree.
The way that data is stored
is through these blackboard keys,
which we kind of already mentioned.
The number of entries available in the blackboard
used to be 255 as of 5.2.
So this blackboard key type that we've said
it used to essentially store an ID under the hood.
Now the ID used to be a UINT8,
which is a value that can only go from zero to 255.
As of 5.2, that changed to an IN32.
So I suspect it's very likely
that we no longer have this cap of 255 entries.
I imagine that's now whatever the maximum capacity
of an IN32 is.
Don't quote me on that.
It's worth exploring on your own.
When I have tried to make blackboards
that have more than 255 entries in them,
they didn't complain.
But you know, be conscious that that is a change
that has taken place, but I can't,
I am not completely certain of the recipe
that there isn't some kind of other place
that is in some way limiting you to 255 entries.
Ultimately, 255 entries is a lot,
accounting for the fact that blackboards
can't store container types.
So they can't have arrays and maps.
And so if you do need, for some reason,
large quantities of actors,
we'll talk about this in a little bit,
actors or any kind of data,
there might be special ways to construct that
to kind of avoid hitting up against this entry limit
if it does exist.
The other thing to mention about blackboards as well
is that blackboards can inherit from each other.
So you can introduce a blackboard
that introduces types A, B, and C,
inherit from that blackboard,
and then you'll automatically get those blackboard keys
introduced to any child blackboards.
So we talked about the kind of like
smaller subset of types
that would be suitable for blackboards.
This would include vector, rotators,
bools, int32s, floats,
a kind of lot of these standard atomic types.
We can also implement U classes, U objects,
so the actual class type itself,
objects, so instances of objects,
F names, enums, strings, structs.
With these kind of specialized types,
like objects and structs and enums,
it's not just a kind of generic,
broad concept of an enum or a struct.
You do actually have the ability to specify
kind of more information about that.
So if you were to specify an object,
you can actually say,
hey, is there a particular class
that this should be inheriting from?
The default would probably be actor.
But also the same thing for an enum.
If you just say this is an enum key,
you can also specify,
is there a particular enum type that this should be?
And lastly, if you went to struct,
similarly, you can specify
what kind of struct should this be using?
So it is not purely just the abstract concept of an enum.
It can be a kind of typed enum.
The other thing to mention is that since Unreal 5.5,
there is also the idea of instance structs.
This is not a talk we're gonna kind of go into those,
but if you're pre-5.5,
I'm not sure that same type will be available to you,
but instance structs are essentially structs
that behave a little bit more like objects
in that they occupy
location in memory on the heap,
and that memory can be shared
between multiple instances of the struct,
giving you that kind of nice editor
editability of a struct,
but with the idea that when you're passing
this struct around,
you're actually passing around a pointer
to a location in memory that is shared.
Worth looking into in your own time,
but just worth mentioning that instance structs
have been introduced as a blackboard type.
For all the types,
it's just worth looking at the blackboard key
all types.header,
just to kind of see all the types available to you,
but this is kind of like
most of the types you would typically be using.
And as I've already mentioned,
container types aren't supported.
So maps, arrays, none of these types would be available.